welcome to today's session
on integrating vm workloads into antho
service mesh
i'm chris grall i'm a product manager in
google cloud
i've been with google for about
project and i've been focused really on
expanding the reach of meshes
to multiple clusters and in this case to
the apps
so before we get into the details of how
we're integrating vm workloads into
service mesh
i want to give a little background and a
little motivation on why we're doing it
so one of the factors behind this is
the microservice trend this is a big
topic in the industry it has been for
some time
and people talk about a lot of things
about microservices
how when you break the monolithic
application up into smaller services
your teams can move faster
they can even decide which language each
team wants to write in some might write
in
java some might write in python it
doesn't matter because they're broken
apart and operate independently
over apis they can
roll out new versions on their own they
don't need to roll out the whole
application at one time
it might be more scalable they can swap
out
something that's has been purpose-built
for maybe a sas service
so there are tons of benefits behind
microservices
but the bottom line is what you're
trying to do is roll
out new solutions for your customers
you're trying to get those solutions out
there faster
and make them better either higher
reliability more functionality
whatever it is you're trying to roll out
solutions to your customers
however this new architecture comes with
some drawbacks as well
right as you break things apart
and now your services are doing a lot
more communication than they used to
so you have to know how they're
communicating you need may need to
secure that communication
since the services are independent then
you may have them logging in different
places so it's harder to debug
so all these things can can lead to some
confusion
some downtime and ultimately unhappy
customers
so what can we do to solve this well
one things we can do is introduce a
service mesh now
a service mesh i've defined here in
generic terms
and it provides several attributes one
is
first off it should be transparent it
should allow us to roll out a mesh
and not have to go in and change
application code
so you don't have to link in libraries
and and things like that
as we talked about with microservices it
should be language independent so it
shouldn't matter whether your component
is written in go or java
it should work in the service mesh and
then you want that service mesh to be
able to
automate a bunch of things for you
whether it's network traffic or logging
or whatever it is
it should be automatic so those are the
kind of things a service mesh can give
you so let's talk about
the antho service mesh and what it does
provide for you
now antho service mesh and sometimes we
use the acronym asm
is built on top of istio it's powered by
istio which is an open source project
that google started and it works on with
multiple partners
we talk about three main attributes of
antho service mesh
the first thing is uniform observability
so the idea is that we can collect
metrics on all communication going on in
the mesh
we know which services are talking to
which other services
we know what the requests per second are
between those services
we can find the error rates and that can
be done just
instantaneously as well as over a time
series
we can even set slos both on
availability and latency so we have
lots of information about what is going
on in the mesh from a traffic
perspective
second we have operational agility so
we are in the network and we can control
that network traffic so we can do lots
of things
we can do canary deployments or blue
green deployments
we can do load balancing and we can do
load balancing with a variety of
algorithms
for testing purposes we can even do
fault injections so you can make sure
your services are resilient
and we can even set quotas
the third attribute is security so first
we have
identities for the different services
and with those identities we can get
certificates
once we have those certificates then we
can enable mtls
so with mtls now we know which services
are talking to to which services
in a secure cryptographic manner and all
the data can be encrypted across the
connection so nobody else can see what's
going on
with mtls then on top of that we can set
access control policies
we have simple things like allow and
deny deny lists
but we have lots of other access control
policies as well
so these are the three big areas of
antho service mesh
so let's talk about how that plays with
vms now so we've known from the very
beginning that vms were critical in the
service mesh
because 80 to 90 of the workloads in
uh in a customer environment are running
on vms or bare metal machines
containers and kubernetes provide a lot
of wonderful benefits
but again most of the workloads are
still running on vms so it's critical we
integrate those into the environment
in this diagram i'm showing a high level
architecture
of what the mesh looks like so on the
left
is a kubernetes cluster and there are
some control plane components running
there
mainly the sdo sidecar injector which
puts proxies beside the pods
for the services running in the cluster
across the bottom i'm also representing
managed control
plane components these are stackdriver
for
logging and metrics traffic director for
controlling the traffic
and the mesh ca for certificates but in
the middle are the vms and again this is
what this session is about
is how we incorporate these vms into
this mesh
now there are a variety of reasons that
workloads are on vms
in some cases that's just where they
need to run
databases have been tuned and run very
well on vms
moving those to containers may or may
not give you the same kind of
performance so a lot of times i see
customers that are still running
their their data stores in vms and it
makes a lot of sense
second we have packaged applications so
some vendors don't support their
applications running in containers
so this particular company may have a
erp
or a crm application and they have to
run it on a vm
in fact usually the vendor will tell
them exactly what distro and what
version of the vm they have to run
most importantly though are probably the
legacy applications these are the
applications that you've built to run
your business
and those are still running on vms they
probably will be for a long time
there's no way that a company has the
budget the time
and the engineers to move everything
over to containers even if that made
sense
so vms are going to be around for a long
time they're the majority of the
workload and we have to incorporate
those into the mesh
so let's start diving into how we're
going to do that
and we're going to talk about managed
instance groups now managed instance
groups are a feature of
gce and they are a set of vms
that all look the same and run the same
kind of workload so for example if you
have a web front end you might want 10
vms running that web front end
you might even want to auto scale you're
doing doing load balancing things like
that
so the way that managed instance groups
are created
in gce is you first create a instance
template
now this template defines what the vm
looks like
how much memory do i want how many cores
do i want
uh what kind of storage what kind of
persistent disks i want
what network the vms are going to run on
all of those things
go in the instance template once they're
in there
the managed instance group is created
and the user tells them
the managed instance group how many vms
should be created
i want 20 vms or i want 100 vms or you
can even do auto scaling i want
somewhere between
15 and 35 vms
so the managed insurance group will spin
up the vms and control how they're
created
the wonderful thing about migs is
because that managed instance group is
controlling the life cycle
it can do health checks on the vms and
kill vms that aren't working correctly
and then restart them again auto scaling
events
if you have auto scaling turn on it will
start and stop vms depending on the load
so what we're doing and sven will go
into a lot more detail on this
is we're adding some features to the the
instance template
so that when the managed instance group
creates vms
it adds the mesh software to them and
allows them to join the mesh
so sven is going to go into more detail
now so i'm going to
try to give a brief overview of the
architecture of the system and i'm going
to use an example
that we're actually going to be using in
a demo later so here we have a gke
cluster
that's running anthro service mesh 1.6
and it has the online boutique sample
application
installed in it but we actually took out
the product catalog service and we moved
that over into a mig
instead of being running in a kubernetes
pod
and i want to talk a little bit about
kind of how antho service mesh
works and the services it relies on
because i think it's important to
understand just
how many different services are involved
in making the mesh actually work the way
you want to
so the first thing that happens when the
mig starts up is that it starts up this
agent that's running in the
in the mig in the vm and that agent
connects over to the dns server running
in kubernetes
qdns and acts as a proxy for that dns
server
and this is used to give service
discovery to the vm just like you get
service discovery and pods
so the same type of mesh services will
be resolved to
ip addresses in that mesh the second
service it talks to is the mesh ca
which is used to mint certificates for
the vm and the way that the this works
in practice
is that the agent is actually acting
kind of as a proxy
so it runs a secret discovery service
that the proxy can connect to
and it proxies that over to the mesh ca
and it gets the ca the ca certificates
from there
so the agent then starts up this onboard
proxy that's running inside the vm
and the proxy is configured to talk to a
control plane component
in here in this picture it's istiod
running in the cluster
and it's also configured to send
telemetry over to stackdriver
so this sends all of the logs metrics
traces
and actually also edges which we use for
our topology graph over the spectrum
and it of course connects to the agent
for those certificates
so we can get mutual tls bootstrapped
the application itself is then proxied
via that envoy proxy and that can be
done one of two ways it's either using
iptables
which is a transparent proxy mechanism
or it can actually also be run in white
box mode where the application knows
about the proxy
and sort of manually interacts with it
um asm
is also relying on the kubernetes api
server for configuration storage that's
actually not pictured here
but that's also another key component of
the system you need a place to store
your configuration things like service
definitions
authorization policies the routing
information basically all the
configuration for the features
that anthro service mesh offers is
provided in that configuration store
okay so let's walk through how we
actually add this mig to the mesh
and we're going to look at the four
different steps here so step one is
configuring the vm's identity
step two is starting up the mig and
connecting it to the services it needs
and then steps three and four are about
registering that vm
as an endpoint in this in the mesh and
selecting that endpoint
or all the endpoints that are relevant
into relevant services
so let's walk through one by one
so the first thing we're going to look
at is the identity space and this gets a
little bit complicated
because on gcp the vms are actually
running as gcp service accounts
not as kubernetes service accounts and
these have a different form so a gcp
service account
there's really two different main ways
that you'd run a vm
you can either use the default service
account for the vm which is just
project number dash compute or you can
use a named service account that you
created
which is service account name at project
and these
would be the identity that the vm starts
up with and is available through the
metadata server built into gce
but in the anthro service mesh we want
to use mesh identities so mesh
identities
are basically um three parts they are a
trust domain
or a workload pool which identifies the
source of the identities
and then they're a namespace and a
service account within that namespace
and so we need to map between these two
and asm for gce
provides a default mapping that will map
those
service accounts from gcp over into
service accounts in anthos we are also
working on making this
configurable so you can map into the
namespaces that you want to rather than
using the default
thing if that doesn't work for you
okay so now we need to actually get that
instance group
started and verify that everything is
actually working
so we do this using the mechanisms that
chris was just talking about earlier
we use an instance template that we
configure with the service proxy
we give it the configuration it needs to
know what it needs to use
and then we connect it to the control
plane components that i was just talking
about
once it's running we can verify that it
works correctly we can check that it's
connected to the control plane and is
getting configuration
we can verify it has a certificate and
rotation is set up properly
and we can make sure that telemetry is
going over to stackdriver and even go
and actually look at that telemetry if
we want to
in stackdriver to make sure it looks
like what we expect
so we have this running but we aren't
able to actually call the vm yet
so we can't route traffic to it yet so
to get traffic to the vm
we need to register it and in anthro
service mesh we do this
through a decoupled mechanism that's
very similar to how pods and services
work in kubernetes
the equivalent in anthro service mesh
for vms is workload entry and service
entry
and a workload entry is basically a
named endpoint in a namespace
it gives us a way to attach labels and
attach a service account to an endpoint
and then that thing can be selected by
the next thing we're going to talk about
which is the service entry
so a service entry basically lets us
create named mappings to endpoints in
the same way that you do with kubernetes
services
except that it can also select workload
entries so just like a kubernetes
service it has
a port or set of ports actually
it has a workload selector that says
what endpoints are selected
and in asm we also let you specify the
host
as a generic opaque string it doesn't
have to just be a kubernetes service we
can actually use other types too
but for using the same service as a
kubernetes one you can just specify the
host
like we did here okay so that's how
this all works and the architecture
let's look at a demo next so in the demo
we're actually going to set up
exactly the architecture i just talked
about
and we're going to show off the three
pillars of anthro service mesh
the observability features the uh
agility um networking and sort of
traffic management features and the
security features
so we'll look at each of those in turn
in this demo
so let's see our demo of vm's running
with antho surface mesh
so in this demo we're going to show the
kind of three main pillars of anthro
surface mesh the
observability features here in the form
of the dashboards
the traffic management capabilities
which we're going to show a little bit
of canarying
of the new version and the security
features
and here we're going to show
authorization policies and this just
gives you a little flavor of kind of
what you can do with
antho service mesh for vms it's not
meant to be a
complete demo of all the good things you
get
so let's get into it
so the first thing we're going to do is
look at what we have created so far
so we have a cluster here a gke cluster
running at the service mesh
this cluster also has the online
boutique sample application installed
except we don't have the product service
so we're also running
a managed instance group with two vms in
it
and they are running about the product
catalog service
for the online boutique instead of
finding them in the cluster so this can
show you
how you can run vms combined with your
kubernetes services
but right now we don't have these things
hooked up together so right now this is
failing because
the mesh doesn't know about those vms so
the first thing we're do is actually
show
that registration step so we're going to
create
a workload entry and a service entry for
the vm so let's look at these
so this is a workload entry for the
product catalog service b1 of it
running on an ip address so let's go
ahead and create it
and let's also look at the service entry
for this and this service entry
basically says the product catalog
service
is all of the workload entries with the
label selector below where the
app is product catalog service so this
will select everything and it's not
actually using the version we'll see
what version
is used for later and this is basically
the same as a kubernetes service except
it can select workload entries as well
as
kubernetes pods so let's go ahead and
create that
and now that we've created that our
online boutique should
be working again and there it is
it's working so once we have this up and
running the first thing we get is all
the telemetry features
so the telemetry because there's load
going through this service
all that telemetry is going to
stackdriver and we can actually see it
in the ether service mesh dashboard so
here's the dashboard for the product
catalog service we can see the requests
per second
error rates latency cpu usage things
like that
you can also use all the other great
features of antho service mesh
dashboards the
health ability to create slos look at
detailed metrics
look at connected service let's do more
diagnostic dives that kind of stuff
so all the same features you expect but
now available for a service running nfpm
okay so the next step is let's do some
traffic management so we want to roll
out
v2 of our service and the only
difference in
b1 and v2 is we're going to have a
slightly different product catalog
catalog in this case we're going to have
different product description and a
different price for this typewriter
so let's go ahead and do that so the way
we do this is we're going to create
another workload entry
and here we use b2 as the version
instead of u1
and otherwise it's the same and we don't
have to actually change
the service entry we just add a new
workload entry which is basically adding
a new endpoint
so let's create that and then we also
need to um create a
destination rule and a virtual service
so let's look at our destination rule
which actually we're already running
so this decimation rule just says that
there's two subsets to the product
cathode service there's a b1 and a v2
and those are selected based on b1 and
v2 labels so very simple
um and let's do a a traffic split so
let's split traffic
50 50 between these now normally you'd
want to do like one percent or 0.1
or something very very small when you're
carrying a new version but here we just
want to show that it works we're
going to go straight to 30
and now if we go back to our typewriter
if we refresh we should be able to see
yep there it is a different version
so the product description changed the
price change it went up a lot
new version works with their
temperatures and if you keep refreshing
you can see sometimes it'll go to b1
sometimes go to v2 it just basically is
flipping a coin and deciding which one
to do
so let's say we're happy with that and
we decide yep let's actually go
full on b2
so we can do that we have a virtual
service that says yeah send it all the
subset v2
and let's apply that
and now if we go to our batik our
typewriter should always be on youtube
and it is
okay so that's a really basic look at
some of the uh network capabilities
now let's look at our final final area
here security
and so we already have mtls set up right
so
these services are all talking to each
other over mutual tls
they each have an identity they have
certificates they're all set up but
we're not actually preventing any access
as long as something has a certificate
it gets through and so we want to do is
be able to say you know only the
services we expect to be calling are
allowed to
so what we use is asm's
authorization policy to do this and
first what we're going to do is show an
authorization policy that just locks it
down completely so that's
a good first step although he clearly
wouldn't want to do this in production
directly
but we can deny all traffic to this
product catalog service
and so all we have to do is create an
authorization policy
it has a selector that matches that
product catalog service
but it has new rules so it doesn't allow
any traffic it just denies it all so
let's go ahead and do that
and once we deny everything if we go
look at our boutique
it gives an access denied error which is
what we'd expect
okay so what about actually allowing the
traffic that we do want well so here we
have a different rule
this is again very simple we have a rule
that just says
if the principal that is calling is the
default service account in the shop
namespace
let it through and block everything else
so let's go ahead and apply that one
and now if we go look at our shop
it works again
and so that is basically what security
looks like
for antho service mesh with vms um and
so between that and the
traffic management that you get from
anthro service mesh and the great
observability features you can see
just how useful this can be for using
virtual machines without the service
mesh thanks thanks spam that was a great
demo
but i have a couple questions i've
received from customers
the first one is what about a single vm
how do i handle that
well so the great thing about migs aside
from all the great features they offer
is that actually they're free
so you can just take your vm and you can
extract an image from it which gsp makes
very easy to do
and you can run that as a single vm
in a single managed instance group and
again that's free there's no extra
charge for that
and it's very easy to do and then you
can get all the great features of megs
including the ability to run a managed
okay um and this is all great
on gce but i have anthos on-prem
and i want to integrate my on-prem vms
how do i do that
so we are actively working on making
that
both supported and very very easy it
won't be quite as easy as we've managed
to make it on gce because we don't have
the equivalent of managed instance
groups
but we do have plans in place to release
a version of anthro service mesh with vm
support for on-prem
where you take a couple more steps than
what we've outlined here
you would be responsible for generating
the configuration that goes on the vm
and installing the hmm proxy there and
we provide
packages to do that but then once you
have that everything else will be the
same as described here you can set up
the same features
it connects to the control plane the
same way and you get all the great
um anthra service mesh uh capabilities
okay and one last question what if i
have
just vms my department or division
is it using kubernetes right now i just
have vms how do i
set up the mesh with those so that is a
excellent question so
during the the architecture overview
that i was giving earlier
i was talking a little bit about the
different services that we need to
connect to
and so three of those services were
still running in the cluster so there
was the
ist2d control plane there was the cube
dns uh
dns resolver and there was the api
server used for configuration store
and the great news is we're working on
managed versions of all of those
so the control plane the managed version
is traffic director which is already
available
through gcp's apis and we're working on
making it available through
anthro surface mesh for dns
we're actively working with the cloud
dns team to actually integrate
the kubernetes dns serving and gce
dns serving into a single system so
actually that will all be built in you
won't need to do anything extra and
again it'll be a completely managed
service
and then finally we're working on making
it a managed version of the api server
so again you don't need to run anything
you can just use the managed api server
and use vms
with all those components fully managed
by google
great okay well thank you very much
yeah great questions and this was a lot
of fun thanks very much